[Applaudissements]
vous allez essayer de trouver qui à
l'huile de foie de morue parmi les
quatre faux cachets alors être de bons
comédiens fait le décompte
attention c'est parti trois deux un top
[Rires]
à votre avenir
julien julien nantes où bennoo la drass
et l'a9 ouais j'ai une série depuis très
longtemps c'est ouais 13 ans et ça ça
veut tout et ça baigne le jour là oui
oui pour vous pour vous non pas pour moi
non mais pour votre fiancée ah oui quand
on jette à l'eau selon la lingerie bien
sûr vraiment quand il ya longtemps
ça fait 13 ans qu'on entend et en 2000
quelque chose des brouettes
tout est de ma gueule un peu oui les
pandas les images